i do not view abortion as a
um as a choice and a right i think it's
always a tragedy and i think that
it should be rare and safe and i think
we should be focusing on how to limit
the number of abortions and they ought
to be able to have a common ground in
consensus to do that
all right people we are live on youtube
rumble and blaze tv i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report i hope you had a
great weekend it's june 27th my birthday
was yesterday i ate a lot i swam in the
pool got a little sun walked the dog
enjoyed myself i hope you did too
because the world is nutty the news is
crazy and everyone seems to be losing
their minds and that's what what we're
going to be covering today obviously the
big thing on friday uh was that at about
10 30 a.m eastern about a half hour
before we went live on this show uh roe
was overturned and of course the
reaction
was obvious and ugly and sort of seeping
all over the country right now so we're
going to review a little bit about
technically what happened with the
reversal of roe what that actually means
at a legal level uh of course we're also
going to cover some of the crazy things
that the democrats are now saying about
abortion and about government and
democracy and self-rule and personal
autonomy and all of that stuff uh and
then we're gonna of course cover the
media reaction to it and then we have i
think a very special cold close for you
today so i hope you'll watch the whole
show because the cold close is really
going to lead us into what i think we'll
be talking about for the rest of the
week related to abortion and everything
else uh real quick guys reminder if you
are in the south florida area i will be
at the miami improv on july 14th look at
that color scheme right there and look
at those cool
sunglasses july 14th miami improv 8 pm
daverubin.com
events if you would like to join me and
before we get to all the craziness let
me talk to you guys about alto ira real
quick you know cryptocurrency may
represent the future of money it's one
of the most exciting investment
opportunities to come for some time and
it's down right now
so it makes you wonder if this is a good
time to get in with an alto crypto ira
you can trade crypto like bitcoin and
avoid or defer the taxes there are
multiple ways to fund your account you
can make a cash contribution you can
transfer cash from an existing ira or
roll over an old 401k you can trade all
you want without the tax headache and
you can create an account in just a
couple minutes ready to take your
investments to the next level diversify
like the pros and trade without tax
headaches open an alto crypto ira with
as little as 10 bucks just go to altoira
dot com slash ruben that's a lto ira.com
ruben start investing in cryptocurrency
today go to altoira.com
ruben and now back to me okay so let's
just do the nuts and bolts of the
reversal of roe v wade we've got some
info here from the daily wire
the us supreme court has overturned the
monumental roe versus wade case that
legalized abortion
across the america
the 6-3 decision in dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization on friday
followed the early may leak of a draft
opinion indicating which way the
justices would rule justice samuel alito
wrote that roe and a subsequent case
planned parenthood vs casey which upheld
roe both must be overturned and the
right to allow
deny or restrict the right to an
abortion must reside with the states
roe was egregiously wrong from the start
its reasoning was exceptionally weak and
the decision has had damaging
consequences and far from bringing about
a national settlement on the abortion
issue
row and casey have inflamed debate and
deepened division alito wrote in his
majority opinion which was strikingly
similar to the earlier leak draft it is
time to heed the constitution and return
the issue of abortion to the people's
elected
representatives okay so that is
the basics what is happening just to be
crystal clear and i know you know this
because you watch this show and you pay
attention to the proper sources but a
lot of people don't this really is about
states rights more than abortion
specifically we're obviously going to
talk a lot about abortion but this is
the supreme court saying there is no
constitutionally guaranteed right
meaning there is nothing
in the constitution of the united states
of america that says you have a federal
right
to an abortion so all they did is
reverse that and say now that goes up
goes back to the states right it's going
back to the states because that's where
it resided the right to an abortion
resided within the states until 1973
when roe v wade went to the supreme
court and then then it became a federal
law so the justices what did the
justices do whether you like the
decision or not regardless of whether
you're pro-choice or pro-life what did
the justices do they looked at the law
they said wait a minute is there a
constitutional
right to an abortion is it in the
constitution and it's not what are
things that are in the constitution well
you guys know about the bill of rights
that was an addendum to the constitution
but we have equality in the constitution
we have our basic rights to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness right these
are things that are in the constitution
uh but abortion is not that's just
simply the truth and we'll dive into the
specifics about abortion in just a
second but here is joe biden in his
immediate response on friday and
surprise surprise
he's lying it's not hyperbole to suggest
a very solemn moment
today the supreme court of the united
states
expressly took away
a constitutional right from the american
people
that it had already recognized
they didn't limit it they simply took it
away
that's never been done to a right so
important to so many americans
but they did it
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country
50 years ago roe v wade
was decided it has been the law of the
land since then
this landmark case protected woman's
right to choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with her doctor
free from entertainment from the
interference of politics
it reaffirmed basic principles of
equality
that women have the power to control
their own
all right first off
the level of irony to listen to this man
talk about personal choice and personal
medical decisions after he was firing
doctors and nurses after he was
mandating vaccines the insane
authoritarian overreach that he and the
democrats and and plenty of republicans
too uh were going after for the last
couple years that they're suddenly so
concerned with what you a woman i'm not
a biologist can do with your body is the
height of hypocrisy right height of
hypocrisy he also slurred a couple words
there but that's that's just usual uh
now what's interesting there is his
direct quote quote the decision took
away a constitutional right
but that's not true
abortion is not in the constitution so
he is lying about that he can say hey i
liked the decision he always says he's
the catholic too so there's a little
something there that doesn't quite add
up but he could say that hey i as a
democrat as the president of the united
states i believe
that abortion
should be fine or good or legal or
whatever but to tell us that it is a
constitutional right is an abject
lie but don't take my words for it
here's scotus the supreme court of the
united states themselves held the
constitution does not confer a right to
abortion
row and casey are overruled and the
authority to regulate abortion is
returned to the people and their elected
representatives now what's interesting
about that is that's
the way the system was set up the system
was set up so there would be maximum
choice you know they're making it sound
like if you listen to the media and the
crazy democrats who we're going to get
to in just a moment they're making it
sound like suddenly there's less choice
involved
that there's less choice but actually by
decentralizing
the abortion issue we are allowing for
more choice some states will have it
some states will not there will be some
states in between you'll be able to go
from one state to another if you don't
like what's happening in your state you
can move if you want to move the other
way you can do that too like choice and
the messiness of the human experience
and democracy and living in a
pluralistic society with people of all
sorts of philosophical and religious
views of the world that's it's all kind
of working right now and again that's
separate from what you think about
abortion okay
but now let's back up because there was
an uh documentary that the daily wire
put out uh from 1991 is when this all
happened the documentary just came out
in the last couple of months uh but the
documentary is all about clarence thomas
uh and he was sworn in as a supreme
court justice and underwent the hearings
back in 1991
and joe biden was one of his biggest
critics
at the time and we found this little
snippet of some of their exchanges that
i thought was pretty interesting
good morning
judge welcome to the blinding lights
finding out what you mean when you say
that you would apply the natural law
philosophy to the constitution is in my
view
the single most important task of this
committee
senator biden was very focused on
natural law
how did that go who knows i have no idea
what he was talking about
i just want to make sure we all know
what we're talking about here that you
and i know at least what we're talking
about here to be perfectly honest with
you i you sit there and you have no idea
what they are talking about
all i know is that he was asking me
these questions about natural law you
know and i know it is a big big deal and
in conclusion
one of the things you do in hearings
is you have to sit there and look
attentively at people you know
have no idea what they're talking about
and it was fine i understood what he was
trying to do i didn't really appreciate
it
natural law was nothing more than a way
of tricking me
into talking about abortion
since many catholic moral philosophers
saw the two things as intimately related
okay so there's much more to that you
can watch the documentary over at the
daily wire i thought it was interesting
because even back then biden was just
this sort of pontificating buffoon
that's what clarence thomas is saying
he's going on and on about natural law
and you know and i know and all this
stuff and it's like he's not really
thought of was well certainly now but
even back then was not really thought of
as a bright person but speaking of
bright people there have been some
critics suddenly of clarence thomas who
have come out of the woodwork and
you're not going to believe this but
they are not the most enlightened set
here's chicago mayor laurie lightfoot
if you read clarence thomas concurrence
he said thank you
clarence thomas
[Applause]
now first off as you know lori lightfoot
is a lesbian
she has no chance of having an abortion
and even if she was not a lesbian there
is no male on this earth who would like
to bang her okay
i did a little polling before the show
couldn't find anyone um but that's the
level of discourse that these people are
now throwing at clarence thomas and at
the other conservative judges now again
put aside what you think about abortion
for just a second if you just have the
basic understanding of law if you have
the basic understanding of any of our
founding documents and the thing is they
it's not that they don't have a an
understanding of it they don't like our
founding documents but they all know
lori lightfoot knows that there and joe
biden knows that there is no reference
to abortion in the constitution so when
they say it's a constitutionally
guaranteed right they know that they're
lying but they don't like the very
fundamental uh underpinnings of this
country and that's really what this is
about but now the attacks on
which wizard made all the rounds on the
sunday shows of course of course it was
aoc and yeah she wants him impeached
that they can now lie
to duly elected members of the united
states senate in order to secure supreme
court
nominee
confirmations and and and seats on the
supreme court this is what we're saying
at a confirmation hearing is an
impeachable offense
i believe so okay i believe so i believe
lying under oath is an impeachable
offense
i believe that violating federal law in
not disclosing income from political
organizations as clarence thomas
did years ago is also potentially an
impeachable offense okay let's be clear
about something if lying under oath is
an impeachable offense then aoc should
be impeached right now and so should
laurie lightfoot and probably joe biden
and pretty much every democrat who is
demanding that we pack the court and
burn down all of our institutions their
oath of office is to defend the
constitution of the united states of
america that is in the very oath of
office it's right there up top right
what are you doing here as a
congresswoman as a senator you are
defending this document the founding
document that defends all of our rights
that's what you're defending do you
think that's what aoc is doing or would
she gladly
burn down the constitution of the united
states would she gladly pack a court so
that one branch of government
could have enough power to destroy
another branch of government she of
course would do that so you want to
start the impeachment game aoc uh we
should probably
start with you that's probably where we
should start uh we've got more from aoc
this decision and this policy will kill
people no matter what their what the
their spin and what their talking points
are and that's what the data shows and
that's what the statistics show we have
many ideas we have some ideas coming
from senator warren signed a letter
along with 25 other democratic senators
asking president biden to explore
opening health care clinics on federal
lands in red states
in order to
help people access the health care and
abortion services that they need
i know that she's not the brightest bulb
but if she thinks that this decision is
going to get people killed does she know
what abortion is
does she know what abortion is say a
seventh a seven month abortion that
she'd be for does she consider that
killing someone she actually doesn't she
doesn't because the left has become
psychotically rabid and
and almost a death cult at this point
you know it really has because if you're
basically okay with seven month
abortions and eight-month abortions and
post-birth abortions uh then you're kind
of a death cult uh and this whole thing
again about packing the court packing
the courts so that one branch right we
have this checks and balances thing
right you guys took civic some of you
know about this aoc does not um
doing that would be again a violation of
her oath of office but it's not just her
uh her whole squad ayanna presley you
know ayanna presley she's another wizard
she wants to pack the court
and finally uh given the extremism the
far-right extremism and the imbalance
and the compromise integrity of the
supreme court we need to expand the
courts
to restore balance and integrity
restore balance like she's obi-wan
kenobi i mean real piece of work these
people um
far right it's the far right that did
this the far right that has these
justices that are far smarter than that
woman or aoc
uh who take their duty very seriously
sometimes they make decisions that
people on the right like sometimes they
make decisions that people on the left
like but if you don't get what you want
we must drastically alter the entire
system and that is the danger of these
people they hate the system that really
is what this is about people think this
is about abortion and again we can have
that abortion debate and i will gladly
share all my feelings about abortion and
again stay tuned for the cold close so
you'll get some of it um
but that's not really what this is about
this is about will the institutions of
democracy stand up as one side tries to
burn them down completely so let's get
some more responses let's get some more
calm and measured responses from some of
the people on the left here's more from
the daily wire actor samuel l jackson on
friday launched a racial attack against
supreme court justice clarence thomas
after the court overruled abortion
decisions in roe v wade and planned
parenthood versus casey effectively
kicking abortion restrictions back to
the states how's uncle clarence feeling
about overturning loving vs virginia
jackson posted to twitter uncle clarence
seems to be a reference to uncle tom a
racial term often used to slander black
americans who buck the mainstream
narrative merriam-webster defines uncle
tom as a black person who is over eager
to win the approval of whites in the
same tweet jackson took another racial
shot at thomas apparently for marrying a
white woman ginny thomas uh loving
versus virginia deciding in 1967 struck
down state laws banning interracial
marriages so look
i don't really care about samuel l
jackson i don't um and i don't really
care about any what any hollywood actor
thinks of anything but of course these
are the types of things that they catch
fire on twitter and people oh yes he's
an uncle tom and he's a sellout and
clearly they're coming for interracial
marriage next and gay marriage next and
all of these things we have the constant
this is the irony this is the peace that
these dingbats are not fully
understanding we have equal protection
under the law we have equality there is
a an actual constitutionally guaranteed
right to marry who you want now we can
have the ins and outs of all of those
other cases in oberpel and all that and
i'll discuss that further over the next
couple weeks as as we keep talking about
all of these things uh but yes he's
gonna he's gonna reverse interracial
marriage the fear-mongering with these
people is absolutely insane and again
what did the decision do it pushed more
choice on people it did not take away
choice it said hey
go live in a place that is more in line
with your values and by the way as we're
going to get to in just a second there
are going to be plenty of democrats who
will gladly fund the baby murder
in their states they will gladly do it
here is the views ana navarro and ana
navarro was on cnn somehow the woman is
on the view and on cnn i mean what deal
with the devil she made i have no idea
uh but she basically wants to kill a
couple of her uh autistic family members
the mother before during and after the
child and i have not anybody could tell
you what you need to do with your life
or with your uterus and because i have a
family with a lot of special needs kids
i have a brother who's 57 and has the
mental and motor skills of a
one-year-old and i know what that means
financially emotionally physically for a
family and i know not all families can
do it and i have a step granddaughter
who was born with a down syndrome and
you know what it is very difficult in
florida to get services it is not as
easy as it sounds on paper and i've got
another another step grandson who is a
very autistic who has autism and it is
incredible and their mothers and people
who are in that society who are in that
community will tell you that they
considered suicide because that's how
difficult it is to get help because
that's how lonely they could go because
they can't get other jobs because they
have financial issues because the care
that they're able to give their other
children
suffers and so why can i be catholic and
still think this is a wrong decision
because i'm american i'm catholic inside
the church i'm catholic when it comes to
me but there's a lot of americans who
are not catholic and are not christian
and are not baptists and you have no
damn right to tell them what they should
do with their body nobody does
there's so much there it's like
okay so first off again the irony of
these people this is the same psycho
lunatic who would sit at that table with
those harpies of the view for the last
two years demanding that you get
injected some with something an
experimental vaccine or you get fired so
her argument about my body my that's all
just complete nonsense and [ __ ]
secondly um we can have an honest
discussion about what sort of uh
benefits there should be at the state
level or federal level or whatever for
children with special needs and whether
that should be done through private
charities or some level uh through the
government and again whether that's
federal or state or whatever that might
be but in essence what she's saying
there is oh i've got these kids in my
family and we should have aborted them
and i'm pretty sure she's not getting
invited to christmas as michael just
pointed out while we were watching that
because i have no doubt that the mothers
of those children the fathers of those
children whether they're autistic or
whatever else they have or for the well
not many people watch cnn but for anyone
who has an autistic child or a child
with with other developmental
disabilities or whatever it might be as
as hard as that is and everyone's
entitled to making their own choices in
life and figuring out how to do things
and again whether it's public funding on
these things or private funding on these
things or whatever it's like basically
she just said we should have aborted
them that that is in essence what she
just said they'd be better off dead than
alive
so that's anna navarro's take on that uh
and it gets worse it gets worse these
people are completely out of control
here's democrat representative jackie
speer uh with a bit of a call for his
direction there is a war out there and
we need to recognize that we've got to
armor up
that's right this is not a drill
there's a war armor up remember lori
lightfoot a couple weeks ago call to
arms i mean they can do all of the
things that they purported uh donald
trump to do uh but do not worry as the
war comes as this handmaid's tale
unfolds right in front of us new york
attorney general leticia james she gonna
fund the abortion so you can go to new
york kill a baby and then uh go over to
coney island and get on the roller
coaster
we've established a fund in the state of
new york to pay for individuals
traveling to new york to seek abortions
for lodging for daycare this is a state
that respects the right of women to
choose
guess what
i'm actually okay with this i i actually
am okay with this i believe in states
rights so if new york wants to become a
haven for abortions if california wants
to become a haven for abortions if
people in new york want their tax
dollars to go so that low-income uh
black
girls in alabama can travel there to
have their babies aborted
and then you know maybe you get like i
don't know you get like a coupon for ice
cream or something while you're there if
that's what new york
residents want their tax dollars to go
to that is democracy and it's messy
that's how it works so okay you have to
decide if you live in new york and you
are governed by these people if that's
something you're okay with your dollars
paying for but that is federalism so
federalism you know sometimes they're
going to do things in states that maybe
you're not that thrilled with as i've
said a couple times i suspect after new
york and california become these
abortion havens and they keep bussing in
truckloads of usually low-income black
and brown girls to have abortions i'm
guessing the optics of it after about
six months are going to look pretty bad
when the numbers start coming in and
people realize boy they've aborted
something like 10x the amount of black
babies as uh as white babies then then
they're going to have a real problem on
their hands
joy reid tweeted this
uh companies covering some or all travel
costs for abortion so these are giant
corporations and we know that these
corporations in essence have all gone
woke there's one interesting one there
we'll get to in a second but these woke
corporations who are saying hey it
doesn't matter where you work meaning
you know our headquarters are in this
state but if you're in a state that
is going to outlaw abortion or limit
abortion to some level we'll fund your
abortions very exciting corporations
will put you on a bus or a plane and if
you work at amazon or bumble or
starbucks or zillow or lyft or netflix
or match your door dash they will get
you that abortion very exciting of
course the interesting one there is that
tesla is on there and uh elon musk we've
been talking a lot about him over the
last couple of months um i don't know
see this is the interesting thing about
elon musk he was sort of becoming this
like conservative libertarian hero to
some degree and i think he's fighting
all the right battles absolutely and
he's he's been a huge asset in the fight
for free speech and to free us from the
tech oligarchs and all of that stuff but
this is the interesting thing about him
he's not a he's not a pure conservative
uh right this is a guy who just said
that he would vote for desantis but
obviously has some leanings uh that are
still left so in in a way although i
don't love the idea of tesla funding
abortions like corporations funding
abortions um it shows you there's a
little diversity in his thought which is
pretty good right uh here's canadian
dictator justin trudeau trying to scare
the hell out of everybody today's a
difficult day
the judgment coming out of the united
states is an attack
on women's freedom quite frankly it's an
attack on everyone's
freedoms and rights
let me be really really clear in canada
we will always
defend women's rights to choose
and continue to work to expand
access to the full range of reproductive
health and services across the country
all right so he's a deeply inauthentic
snake person
interestingly canada
allows for abortion for any reason up
until the moment of birth is that
correct so eight months in
eight months in that's what canada does
and canada i guess are the good guys in
this case a lot of dead
late-term babies
uh and that makes you a good guy somehow
right and this is an attack on women's
freedom suddenly all these people know
what women are which is also rather
extraordinary uh now interestingly a
couple years ago about 10 years ago
justin trudeau wasn't that into abortion
now i'm getting guff from the other side
because i said i don't like abortion
does anyone whose pro-choice as i am
really like abortion now that was when
justin trudeau was actually
sort of sane when because he wasn't
always a complete far-left maniac but
what happens is you give these guys an
inch and they take a mile this is what
has so consistently happened with almost
everyone on the left virtually every
lefty they've got no emergency brake the
car is going towards the cliff they know
it's going towards the cliff and there's
just no emergency brake instead they
just put their the pedal to the metal
that's consistently
why they
end up in these crazy positions where 10
years ago he was saying i don't like
abortion and now it's horrific that in
the united states they will let states
choose about abortion it's rather
extraordinary related to my own
political evolution i guess i guess
somewhere along the way i decided that
having an emergency break was important
and i think that's why i've evolved out
of this uh complete leftist lunacy i
mean that that really is where we're at
but okay so how did we get here and
let's talk a little bit about how they
can't stop themselves uh bill maher who
i often describe as a slow-motion
conservative and his moment of truth
will come
this coming november when we'll get to
see uh if he's going to be still
supporting democrats and i suspect that
he will unfortunately
he does get it on a lot of things he
just gets it in slow motion here he is
getting it about democrats
and then there's abortion
a difficult issue for the democrats to
lose on but they're trying
for decades liberals have said if only
men could get pregnant this wouldn't
even be an issue
and abortion rights are women's rights
well that's wrong now or as the kids say
hold up
when the wokey end of the progressive
spectrum talks about abortion now they
shy away from that word women and prefer
terms like birthing people
or people who menstruate oh democrats
let's take the first
word a human animal understands mama
and replace it with something best
understood by four trotskyites at
berkeley
[Laughter]
bill once again you're right
you're right but you're right in slow
motion the left has gone completely
bananas so when you talk about the wokey
end as if that has not completely
infected the entire host that is where
your mistake is show me a democrat who
is against seven month abortions
show me a democrat who is against
critical race theory show me a democrat
who's against woke-ism i don't mean a
couple pundits like you i mean people
who are in power to actually do anything
about this
that is the problem you refuse yourself
bill maher to pull that lever that
emergency lever and get off the crazy
train and yes ally with some people that
you think are religious and crazy who
are defending the world that you purport
you want to live in i saw this
spectacular
twitter thread i had never heard of this
twitter account before but i thought it
so summed up exactly what's going on
here and so much of what i've been
talking about for years and i was elated
because it's like yeah normies regular
people are starting to get what's going
on here you know it's not just you
fringe crazy people watching the reuben
report so this is a twitter account
known as loan rides and let me just read
this thread for you i think it just
really gets to the heart of it you don't
like the decisions yesterday and today
you're really not going to like the next
part i mean it's your fault but you're
not going to like it see we were cool
with the status quo yeah we wanted
abortion to go back to the states yeah
we wanted gun rights expanded yeah we
wanted our kids safe from lgbtq
indoctrination but it wasn't enough to
fight about we thought you were like us
that we could argue and make small gains
and lose some ground but everything's
staying fairly level and level-headed
but boy were we wrong because while we
were copacetic and just going along to
get along you were pushing
you pushed abortion from legal safe and
rare in these specific instances you
push now to the point of post-birth
abortion on demand for any reason
you push gun control from background
checks and gun-free zones to now red
flag laws which deny due process
you push the rights of gay marriage to
now the right of lgbtq teachers telling
kindergartners about their sex life and
during all of this you push disagreeing
politically to calling us nazis and
justifying violence against us
justifying harming our families and our
jobs
so now we push back we pushed back with
trump we pushed back with state
legislators we pushed back with school
boards and we haven't even begun to push
back kiddo
we're going to push abortion back to the
rare side in many states we may give you
a time frame like 12 to 15 weeks about
what your beloved other industrialized
nations give we may not we're going to
push back on the lgbtq agenda we're
going to make your lives miserable when
you try to get our kids to question
their gender we're going to remove the
power you think you have and put it in
the hands of parents
you had a chance to call it truce you
had a chance to be in control and happy
you had a chance to just leave us alone
you didn't
you pushed and prodded and provoked and
you're threatening to commit violence
now good luck with that
there's a saying about the danger of
making people who want to be left alone
get involved you've made us get involved
so all of it from here on out is
squarely on you
enjoy the whirlwind you have so
deservedly reaped
credit
to this anonymous person who put that
thread together isn't that
just it i just know exactly what you're
feeling right now
that that is it the right has been
willing conservatives have been willing
to live and let live i can tell you this
my life is a living breathing example of
this i just finished a two-month book
tour where my audience is almost all
conservative at this point you know it's
some mix of conservative libertarian
ex-lib something like that but largely
conservative most of the people who
watch this show think of themselves as
conservative i am married to a man i am
about to have kids
um and and you guys support me some of
you may have your own religious beliefs
about my life but you were willing
conservatives were willing when it came
to marriage equality okay trump moved
the dial on that we moved on but then
they couldn't stop so that it was about
talking to your kids about gender theory
privately at public schools this idea of
it never
stopping we just want more abortion safe
and rare
right early stages
to cheering eight-month abortions they
cannot stop themselves and now they have
pinned it's not even conservatives
that's the thing they have pinned decent
thoughtful
evolved people who just want to be left
alone
to suddenly have to use state power to
push back against their their insanity
so this is squarely on you progressives
this is squarely on you wokesters it's
squarely on you remaining democrats who
do nothing in the face of the insanity
that your side has provoked this is on
you bill maher and you people who keep
voting for the people that bring all
this in even as you go but i'm not
exactly like them
and now you have created i think
what is going to be the widest tent in
america and it will always be my job in
that tent to be a little more on the
libertarian side of it a little more on
the liberal side of it i am certainly
not a traditional say religious
conservative and then that's where we'll
be able to play but those people are
pissed right now and they're rightfully
pissed because they said okay
have gay marriage and you guys said no
we want to talk to your six-year-old uh
about gender identity and you can't
blame them for being pissed but the
point here is and this is sort of the
silver lining on all this is that
federalism is winning the united states
is winning right now the founding
documents of the united states are
standing up for themselves that we
wouldn't have centralized power the
federal government demanding the states
do things things it doesn't matter what
you think about abortion in this case
that's what i'm that's what i'm really
trying to drive home to you guys yes
this is about abortion at some level but
it's really about where does power sit
and the more local power sits the more
power that you will have over your own
life and we should not forget
that the united states is still the
shining beacon it's still the best
example of that in the world and even on
cnn this weekend jake tapper interviewed
uh british prime minister boris johnson
and yeah he gets it about america
we're here at the g7
a gathering of the world's leading
democracies when i talk to friends in
canada the uk australia and elsewhere
people express concern
about the united states as the united
states about the united states in terms
of our ability in our institutions to
to thrive and continue after what
happened
uh with the election of 2020. they worry
that
democracy is on life support in the
united states are you worried at all do
you like no i want to say this to the
people of the united states i'm not i
think that i i'll just get back to the
what i've been trying to say to you
throughout this interview i think that
uh reports of the death of democracy in
the united states are grossly grossly
exaggerated
america is a shining city on a hill and
for me
and it will continue to be so but i
don't believe that american democracy is
under serious threat far from it i
continue to believe that america is the
greatest global guarantor of democracy
and freedom
guess what guys people outside of
america they still want america to be
good
they still want america to lead they
still want us to be that shining beacon
that shining star that hope that dream
and we still have a chance to do it we
really still do
have a chance to do it the cold clothes
that we're going to throw to in just a
moment is actually an excerpt from don't
burn this book my first book about
abortion and i think you'll find it to
be quite thoughtful it's audio so you'll
hear me reading from the audiobook if uh
if you haven't read the book or listen
to the book i think you'll you'll dig it
but the portion i think is is pretty
apropos and really i think what's going
to set us up for the rest of the week
because again today we didn't really
talk about abortion so specifically this
was about what's going on
constitutionally legally and culturally
but it is worth having that conversation
about abortion and how we all come to
our conclusions and what that delicate
balance between personal choice and the
government should be and all of those
things so hang tight for that uh it is
me monday over on the reuben report
locals community i posted this one this
morning we've never had a baby formula
shortage until men started getting
pregnant and there is the great the
legendary burgess meredith who was the
penguin in the batman series in the 60s
and uh he was also the voice of globulus
in the gi joe movie for those of you
paying attention at home
and of course he was in grumpy old men
that's where that image is from uh
locals comments uh this or let's start
here was one from rell on rumble how is
it legal to use tax dollars to transport
people from out of state to use
tax-funded medical facilities well look
there's going to be all sorts of these
things that are now going to transpire
and i just can't imagine you know it's
hard for me to imagine people that are
somewhat sane living in blue states at
this point but like if you are
solidly
pro-life let's say the idea that your
tax dollars would go so that you could
import somebody from another state so if
they get abortion here state is is kind
of crazy but maybe this will just
continue that that great movement that
is happening throughout the country and
people will be doing that federalist
thing and voting in essence with their
feet and going to where they want to be
california is working on the abortion
practical support fund which will cover
abortion travel expenses
so congratulations california you'll be
able to go to california have an
abortion get your five-year-old son's
penis chopped off and then go over to
disneyland
kathy on locals says i don't think lori
understands anything about the law at
all well that's the point right lori
lightfoot she doesn't care about the law
i mean can we get the numbers why do we
get the chicago numbers it's a little
off topic for today but how many people
were killed and shot in chicago this
weekend just to see because she is the
mayor of chicago and she doesn't care
about the law i mean people are being
killed in her city all the time she
doesn't care about that here we go we're
going to get the shot and killed numbers
from chicago but the point is that these
people
they don't like the institutions do you
think that if aoc had the power to
completely take out the
judicial branch of government the
supreme court the court system would she
do it of course she would of course you
would do you think lori lightfoot would
gladly burn the constitution if she
could of course she could so that's the
bigger problem when it comes to all of
these things everything that happens
when they don't get what they want it's
more fuel to what their
true goal is which is a burning down of
the system 25 people were shot in
chicago this weekend five were killed
that's a pretty light weekend for lori
light but hence why she was obviously
out at that party where she was telling
clarence thomas to go f himself uh amy
over on local says aoc gives bartenders
a bad name ain't it the truth aoc would
have been a great character in one
episode of cheers right where they bring
in like one
this really entitled
[ __ ] self-serving awful
girl to be a bartender and she gets you
know sam kind of uh sam alone uh you
know ted danson's crushing on her at the
beginning but by the end he realizes man
she's just awful then he goes and he
bangs kirstie alley
there you go uh guys a reminder you can
join me in miami daverubin.com events if
you want to join
if you want to join me on july 14th my
full episode with devin nunes former
congressman from cali a saiyan
congressman from cali who is now running
trump's truth social all about big tech
and all that stuff uh is up across
platforms right now and uh thank you for
watching the show today here's the the
cold clothes which as i said this is a
clip from don't burn this book my first
book so i wrote this about four years
ago
talking about the abortion issue and uh
listen to it and i think that's going to
kind of frame what we'll do going
forward this week okay have a great
monday everybody
before this process started i'd always
been solidly pro-choice though in the
last two years or so i've begun to
describe myself as begrudgingly
pro-choice after learning more about the
biology of gestation and the process of
abortion and seeing the left fetishize
it in a way that i'm not comfortable
with
there are countless videos on youtube of
women celebrating their terminations
while organizations such as shout your
abortion encourages twitter users to do
the same with carefree abandon of course
using colorful eye-catching images
and the necessary role of public policy
which protects our freedoms in the first
place
this is a situation in which personal
views of morality and public standards
of law butt heads in an intractable
opposition
my libertarian side says that the
government should have nothing to do
with this decision but my realist side
says that the state has a duty to
protect the life of the unborn the
question here is when
i believe the classical liberal approach
to abortion comes down to if and when
one personally decides it's okay to have
an abortion
this is the constant push and pull
between the private and the public my
position of 12 weeks puts the focus on
the mother up until a point then says
the government must protect the life of
the child beginning at that point
when the issue is viewed through this
lens i think we can have a powerful
debate as to whether the 12-week marker
is fair or whether it should be 6 weeks
or 20 weeks
classical liberalism doesn't demand that
you bow to it it instructs you to make a
decision for yourself then through that
process we can figure out what is best
for society at large
this is in contrast to the traditional
conservative position which has been
firmly pro-life it is also at odds with
the ever-changing position of
progressives which now sees no end to
when a woman can have an abortion
my belief is that the only way to
negotiate this complex issue is to make
a compromise even if it will most likely
upset people on both sides
in other words the belief in individual
freedom must extend to having confidence
in people making the best decisions for
themselves even if we personally believe
they are ethically and morally wrong
this is the balance between individual
rights and the light touch of government
you may not be thrilled with the outcome
but it takes into account the widest set
of opinions and tries to offer as much
choice as possible within reason
you